les réunions chez où nous + 4
chez vintage en acheteurs allait super
et puis quand banier
merci maman déchets doctissimo je me
suis enlevé le petit pont et voir du
territoire un cancer du col de même
cette équipe au raku fait aller pour
l'heure à l'elysée je viens de croiser à
l'instant le ministre de l'économie dans
les couloirs il m'a demandé de toute
urgence d'organiser une réunion afin de
parler des derniers chiffres du chômage
alors cette anecdote est elle vraie
beauté de fausses
c'est pas chez d'autres termes un moule
acheminés chez bamboo mais c'est pas
vrai ils veulent faire passer une loi ou
les utilisateurs devraient prouver
qu'ils ont plus de 18 ans et plus à la
demande d'alain tricycle saison ça va se
battre on n'a pas aimé d'ailleurs il
arrive bon alors c'est quoi cette
histoire moi j'ai 40 c'est toi la preuve
j'appuie sur g + 18 ans au musée grévin
à
recommencer
je n'ai plus rien aux soit pas fait
gaffe à la caf et j'ai planqué plein
dire hiverner à l'elysée comment il
s'appelle le
ministre est faux
c'est vrai bien chez ali express j'ai
reçu meilleur pote c'est allier express
à de vrais bons jours sur attention
didier a commandé sur wii ça donne un
faux avait été telle était petit comme
samsung et paf on ne relève l'adaptateur
secteur mais comment ils font pour
recharger leurs téléphones il se démerde
mais je comprends pas bien la démarche
mais si c'est une démarche éco logique
nomique
chez apple samsung en les chargeurs de
langoat pour faire quoi que c'est écolo
mais il faut qu'on fasse exactement
pareil même plus loin on aurait fait ça
ces démarches éco nomique g borne bon
allez je vous laisse je me casse je dois
aller chercher monde à dos y aller en
voulait 6 aux halles il est petit qu'on
salue galère il fait plus jeune des 47
j'aurais dit 40 chez décathlon bon
concernant le bilan de fin d'année pour
le rayon chasse et pêche et lorient
tennis de table il va falloir qu'on se
mette d'accord sur une stratégie chez
les daft punk maintenant qu'on est
séparé on peut se dévoiler nos identités
au début ça doit rester entre nous
évidemment
à temps mais depuis le début tu es
stéphane plaza bien sûr et toi tu es
joueur
tu ne sauras jamais en lebastard chez
mcdo vers lui on a remis le monopoly
j'adore je gagne un mcflurry le gagner
une petite flûte non j'ai rien
chez facebook eu mais le fait que
pour avec moins de plus aussi vérifier
les faits cloud on change de nom on
s'appelle meta knight n'a pas bien
compris ce qu'on crée un monde virtuel
mais taper avec un casque vert et à
vapeur avec les idées de tous bords ont
créé le métavers ce roman de tous qui
n'existe pas aller au travail chez
décathlon la réunion est terminée allez
allez oui ou non il faut tourner en fait
principe en or mais attention les
sardines en géant c'est monsieur n'zi
même s'il vous plaît le dernier en
musique je n'ai plus d'idées jarratt
allez on passe à patienter non j'ai dit
non
c'est génial ça c'est exactement ce
qu'on cherche je vous envoie la facture
chez les daft punk
vous ne saurez jamais j'ai fais un méta
est pas mal les méta nerf au bled j'aime
bien mais oui on est en réunion tout en
restant inscrits chez nous que j'adore
et louis l'aide ouais je sais pas
demandez pas ce qui se passe d'accord je
ne peux pas changer ozil
c'est pourquoi l'association
où les pauvres contrôlés pour que les
pour les baux dont les ss ce
court-circuit c'est pas vrai
fonctionnement des appareils thomas
pesquet il faut je fais un tick tock
pour qu'on appelait déjà le jeu
flamboyant nous aviez promis oui ben oui
la prime fait l'inra tête de tigre
j'ai amazon les chiffres sont excellents
sata mais bravo monsieur b dos au new
zealand moscou devenu l'homme le plus
riche du 1er au no comment regardez vous
allez quand même 200 milliards monsieur
vélo
chez tesla voilà je vais lui passer
devant à l'hôtel the future is enfin
messieurs masque à noël approchant
amazon risque de prendre un peu de
valeur un bon bout voilà jeff bezos
s'est repassé premier
physique chez amazon vous avez bien lu
régiment de ce biseau ce wee-end losc a
seulement deuxième avec sa fusée
désormais
si vous refusez et mac on dirait que moi
je vais te temps chez playmobil et pas
félicitations vous pouvez signer votre
augmentation super choisi à les
isoler j'arrive seul après justin bluffé
pied
dans l'île c'est ce qu'attend question
non
non non c'est bon au 1er nov on dit que
c'est moi c'était mon premier gala ligne
un
saxophone alors je vais tomber dans le
piège
c'est juste ici pour voir le bêtisier et
les scènes coupées
allez vas-y
c'est bon pour pour sa chaîne epix si
minable je te fous sur la prochaine
série ça va cartonner j'espère que c'est
pas encore l'adaptation live d'addario
japonais parce que